cbs news investigation reveals a
frightening tactic used by cyber
criminals
there are going after coveted user names
which can be bought and sold at online
marketplaces sometimes for tens of
thousands of dollars and they're willing
to harass people to get them our lead
national correspondent david begno shows
us how criminals are even faking
emergencies to torment victims
this was the cabin here in the woods of
central tennessee where mark herring
went to just get away from it all a
retired software developer his daughter
corey and ex-wife fran told us that he
so often warned the family about
internet safety what would he say to you
to be careful and to not trust anybody
you don't know who is behind that screen
you never know
who's on that computer
herring was the proud owner of a very
unique twitter handle at tennessee he
scooped it up in the social media sites
early days by 2020 strangers were asking
him if they could buy it from him and
he'd tell him no because he will he
loved his handle then one night last
year this is elena how can i help you
his local sheriff's department got a
chilling 9-1-1 call i just shot someone
you just shot
somebody the voice on the phone claimed
to be mark herring but the call was a
hoax it was part of a plan to scare the
real mark herring into turning over his
twitter handle handles like herrings
have become really valuable status
symbols there's a big marketplace for
this kind of stuff online these short
instagram handles are really unique
names if you go to this website
ogusers.com
apparently somebody offered 12 grand for
this but it says if you give us 25 000
now on the spot we'll give it to you the
bad actors are exploiting these websites
cbs news has learned of a growing
criminal enterprise where victims across
the country say they were threatened for
their social media handles
it happened to this arkansas man with a
one-year-old child he was told by his
harasser surrender your instagram handle
or i'm calling child protective services
how would you describe what they did to
you
extortion digital extortion
and
just robbing people of their own
security meet marie she spoke with us
under the condition that we not tell you
her real name
she described to us how her tormentors
harassed her just for her instagram
handle i started getting pizza sent to
my house
at all times did they pay for the pizza
the driver thought
that i'd be paying cash there would be
four to five pizzas or food deliveries
in a row
like bi-weekly
yes
and
it it was just relentless now marie's
handle was just two letters her initials
but that could sell for thousands of
dollars online did you ever think of
just turning it over and saying just
leave me alone here it is no why not
it's mine i guess imagine if that was
the norm
just to say hey i want something that
you have give it to me and you do
then one night marie had just finished
dinner with her kids when the police
showed up they started screaming at me
that
you know they wanted to know what was
going on in my house
and
nothing nothing was going on in my house
they told me somebody just called and
said that there was a bomb in my house a
police report showed that the bomb
threat was fake called in by someone who
wants the victim's instagram username
it's almost as though you're being
watched by someone invisible that you
you don't know who it is and you don't
know how far they'll go assistant u.s
attorney deb ireland says these cases
are hard for federal officials to
investigate and they're even harder to
prosecute because there are no statutes
that explicitly outlaw calling in fake
emergencies it is a tactic known as
swatting law enforcement arrives ready
to deal with a true emergency and they
arrive with
all the tools at their disposal and that
is exactly what happened to mark herring
in the woods of tennessee last year i'm
gonna blow this pipe up man i just want
to kill myself herring was watching tv
when more than a dozen police cruisers
showed up
he went out to his back porch the
officers had their guns drawn and they
ordered him climb under this gap in the
gate and keep your hands up as he stood
up he collapsed mark herring the man who
had preached internet safety suffered a
fatal heart attack i think about what
was going through his mind
oh he was scared to death
i guarantee i believe that's what killed
him just being scared to death
one week later the fbi arrested shane
saunderman a 20 year old
prosecutors say he arranged the herring
swatting call and was part of a criminal
ring that would annoy harass and
intimidate victims into giving up their
social media account names so that they
could then
sell them online to the highest bidder
saddening it's maddening it's disgusting
and it's criminal and it's criminal
that same criminal ring also targeted
marie now she tried unsuccessfully to
scrub her name off the internet
altogether
but don't you know when shane saunderman
was first released on bail marie got
this text message from an anonymous
number i will start harassing your
family again and if you do not give me
the account i will be doing it every day
how can you choose your instagram over
your family you spiteful
and nice try removing yourself off the
websites your information is saved with
me smiley face emoji
it's shocking
shane sonderman pleaded guilty to
conspiracy he was sentenced in july to
five years in prison we wanted to talk
to him we asked we tried we tried again
but never got a response
you know the person who called mark
herring and scared him to death as his
daughter said
that was a 17 year old kid in the united
kingdom who has not been arrested so far
why not him
good question i asked the prosecutor
that and
there wasn't a great answer in terms of
why not go after him i mean you have the
you know things with the different
countries law enforcement that thing but
it's like why not go get him too so as
more of our life moves online we're
going to see more of these like digital
muggings for things of value and there's
a technique called sim swapping uh that
can be used here tell us about that it's
fascinating so here's here's what
happened it happened to marie right so
they called these bad guys essentially
they called her phone company and said
hey i lost my phone can you port my
number to this new phone i got a new
phone they're protected
that's right so it happens and that's
how they get access to marie's phone
that's how they get access to her social
media account and that's how they change
the password and then they own the
handle they're in charge of the handle
it seems like they'd have to ask some
security questions before they just hand
over
because anybody could say because if you
have two factor that doesn't help that's
going to get around scary stuff very
scary david thank you very much